um 45 seconds to make it Kinder in
Sicherheit zu bringen 45 Sekunden um in
den Keller zu gehen 45 Sekunden so lange
dauerte es früher
Raketen die aus Russland kommen und die
Stadt Haag Heft treffen nachdem man die
Sirenen gehört hat
ich habe Teenager in der Ostukraine
getroffen für die ein zählen bis 45 Teil
des täglichen Lebens geworden ist
Teenager Großmutter Väter die nichts
anderes wollen als dass dieser Krieg
endet sie wollen Frieden
der russische Aggressionskrieg hat nicht
nur fürchterliches leid für die Menschen
in der Ukraine gebracht der Krieg hat
gähnende Wunden weltweit geöffnet
Familien auf allen Kontinenten die nicht
zurechtkommen angesichts steigender
Energie und Lebensmittelpreise alle von
ihnen und die meisten von uns hier sind
sich in einem einfachen Punkt einig wir
wollen dass dieses Leiden aufhört in der
Ukraine und weltweit wir wollen dass
dieser Krieg endet wir wollen Frieden
Posting ist und das Gute ist dass wir an
Friedensplan haben der jetzt direkt vor
uns liegt nämlich die Karte der
Vereinten Nationen
ihre Prinzipien gelten für alle Staaten
und sind sehr einfach
Souveränität
territoriale und Versehrtheit und die
nicht Anwendung von Gewalt deshalb ist
die Straße hin zum Frieden sehr klar
Russland muss seine Truppen aus der
Ukraine zurückziehen Russland muss mit
dem bombardieren aufhören Russland muss
zurückkehren zur unokata jeder von uns
hier hat heute die Chance an Beitrag zu
diesen Friedensplan zu leisten indem man
dem Aggressor sagt er soll aufhören
indem man klar macht das ist kein
Frieden ist wenn der
Aggressor dem Opfer sagt es sollte
einfach aufgeben und es ist kein Frieden
wenn der Aggressor belohnt wird für
seine ruchlose Gewalt das liefere den
Wesen der Kater der Vereinten Nationen
zu wieder es würde keinen Frieden
bedeuten sondern mir Gewalt aus diesem
Grunde unterstützen wir die Ukraine in
ihrem Recht auf selbst Verteidigung so
wie in Artikel 51 der uno-karten
niedergelegt
ich habe auch heute
gehört dass einige von ihnen gesagt
haben das durch die Bewaffnung der
Ukraine wir Öl ins Feuer gießen
da habe ich eine ganz aufrichtige Frage
an Sie weshalb um Himmels willen würden
wir so etwas tun wir wollten diesen
Krieg nicht wir haben diesen Krieg nicht
gewählt
wir würden uns wirklich ihr darauf
konzentrieren unsere ganze Energie unser
ganzes Geld unsere Schulen wieder in
Ordnung zu bringen die Klimakrise zu
bekämpfen und die soziale Gerechtigkeit
zu stärken aber die Wahrheit ist
Russland aufhört zu kämpfen dann endet
der Krieg wenn die Ukraine aufhört zu
kämpfen dann ist das das Ende der
Ukraine und das menschliche Leiden würde
jeden Tag weitergehen
Entführungen Vergewaltigung Folter
Kinder die bis 45 zählen und das jeden
Tag um ihr Leben zu retten
diese
Zerstörung würde anhalten Inflation
Energie Knappheit und Hunger deshalb ist
die heutige Abstimmung auch eine
Abstimmung über unser aller Zukunft jede
von uns hier muss heute seine
Entscheidung zu treffen entweder
isoliert dazu stehen mit dem
unterdrucker oder sich mit anderen
zusammen zu schließen für den Frieden zu
schweigen oder unsere unokat hat zu
schützen damit die Kater uns schützen
kann vielen Dank
[Musik]
eine kurze Rede einer eindringliche Rede
von Anna-Lena baerbock dort in New York
vor der Vollversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen zum nur zur neuen Resolution
zum Krieg in der Ukraine die Ukraine
selber hat sie angebracht Professor
Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaftler der
Universität Köln hat mit zugehört Herr
Jäger
hatte dort wieder das angesprochen was
auch gestern der UN-Generalsekretär
gesagt hat das ist ein Krieg der uns
alle betrifft wie sehr verhängt dieses
Argument noch
und das verfängt vor allem in der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen und das hat die
bundesaußenministerin ja sehr geschickt
gemacht indem Sie hier den Aggressor
gegen die Kater der Vereinten Nationen
gestellt hat indem sie sich darauf
eingelassen hat auf der einen Seite zu
berichten wie schwer die Bedingungen in
der Ukraine sind und was die ukrainische
Bevölkerung zu erwarten hätte wenn sie
denn unter russische Herrschaft leben
müsste das ist ja die eine Dimension
gewesen aber das andere war insbesondere
eben zu sagen hier geht es nicht bei der
Abstimmung darum zwischen der Ukraine
und Russland zu wählen das geht darum ob
wir die Kater der Vereinten Nationen
ernst nehmen oder Opfer sie nicht ernst
nehmen und das war ein gutes Argument
das war ein gutes Argumente
Zimmermann die FDP
sicherheitspolitikerin hat ja gesagt
wenn Russland sieht dann können wir auch
sofort im übertragenen Sinne die
Vereinten Nationen begraben dann haben
sie keine Funktion mehr würden sie das
auch sagen
nein die Vereinten Nationen sind ein
schwierige internationale Organisation
die man erfinden müsste wenn es sie
nicht gäbe aber sie haben in den ganzen
Jahrzehnten hat damit zu tun dass sie
eben doch nicht so funktionieren wie
sich das alle immer wünschen die gemäß
dieser Kater leben wollen sondern es
gibt immer wieder Krieg es gibt immer
wieder Brüche dieser dieser Kater und es
gab immer wieder Situationen im
Sicherheitsrat in dem dieser nicht
handlungsfähig war sondern durch den
Veto blockiert waren er ehrlich gesagt
das war die Mehrheit meistens ging es
eben so dass einer der eine der Veto
möchte betroffen war und deshalb dort
die Zusammenarbeit blockierte aber
deswegen zu sagen die Vereinten Nationen
sein nicht sinnvoll oder man müsste sie
abschaffen das ist keine kluger kein
kluger Schluss da raus die territoriale
Unversehrtheit das ist ja das äh was
immer wieder betont wird aus vielen
Mündern jetzt auch sehr häufig natürlich
auch in dieser
vollversammlungsdebatte die Reden die
dort gehalten in China sagt das wir
sagen dass das Zeitalter der
Grenzziehung und Waffen das ist doch
eigentlich vorbei das war mal das
Zeitalter der Kolonialisierung
eigentlich
das haben wir gedacht dass wir
Imperialismus und Kolonialismus hinter
uns gelassen haben und auf anderen
Kontinenten ist das ja ebenfalls
wirklich nun gravierendes Thema wo die
Grenzen zum Beispiel eben durch
Kolonialmächte gezogen wurden und wo es
alle Laie Rückbesinnung auf historische
Grenzen geben könnte die dazu führen
dass man jetzt Krieg gegeneinander
führen muss und die Grenzen allein in
Europa haben sich in den letzten
Jahrhunderten derart verändert das ist
einfach keinen Sinn macht
zurückzublicken und zu sagen es ist im
geschichtlichen Verlauf mal eine Grenze
gewesen die uns das Recht gibt sie jetzt
wieder einzufordern nein das ist dann
imperialistischer Gedanke der eben genau
das beiseite wischt was sich die Staaten
mit der Kater Vereinten Nationen
vereinbart haben nämlich die Grenzen
bleiben jetzt bestehen wir müssen
irgendwann der Geschichte der Menschheit
Mann machen und wo wir nicht
zurückschauen wo wir nicht
revisionistisch sehen da ist doch der
rhetorium auf dass wir irgendein
historischen Anspruch haben könnten oder
irgendeinen anderen bei anderen
begründeten Anspruch und Russland bricht
das und darum wird jetzt gerade gerungen
mit dieser Resolution mit Worten bei den
Vereinten Nationen bei der
Vollversammlung Professor Thomas Jäger
herzlichen Dank für die Einschätzung für
die Analyse nach Köln heute Nacht wird
die Abstimmung erwartet meine Damen und
Herren und wir sind sehr gespannt wie
sie ausfällt
und wir gehen jetzt einmal einen ganz
anderen Aspekt dieses Krieges an auch
ein Aspekt nämlich der wie dieser Krieg
in der Ukraine die Umwelt zerstört
der Krieg in der Ukraine er wütet weiter
die russischen Angriffe dauern an
es ist ein erbarmungsloser Krieg der
viele Menschen leben